Transcription: Tomas Rojo
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Dans une grande entreprise, tu as le choix
entre te soumettre et te démettre.
Cette phrase, je l'ai entendu
de la bouche d'un dirigeant.
Te soumettre ou te démettre.
Sérieusement, tu vas passer 80 00 heures
à travailler tout au long ta vie,
à y mettre ton énergie,
ton temps, tes talents
et les deux seules options
qu’on te proposerait,
c’est de te soumettre ou de te démettre.
Nous, nous pensons qu’il existe
une troisième voie et cette voie,
c’est celle de l’engagement.
Bonjour, je suis Alexis, ancien salarié
de Michelin pendant sept ans.
Bonjour, je suis Pauline.
J’ai rejoint le monde de l’entreprise
il y a cinq ans au sein d’une PME,
puis au sein de grands groupes, dont Suez.
Aujourd’hui, nous voulons
vous partager une conviction.
Les entreprises ont un rôle énorme,
primordial,
à jouer dans les transformations
environnementales et sociales.
Elles font partie du problème.
Ça, c'est indéniable.
Oui, Pauline, mais elles font
aussi partie de la solution.
Et vous faites partie de la solution
Ce n’est pas parce que vous avez eu
un déclic écologique
que vous devez fuir les entreprises
au motif qu’elles ne le sont pas assez.
Mais avant de vous expliquer comment,
revenons un peu en arrière
Nous sommes en 2018.
Pauline et moi
ne nous connaissons pas encore.
Je travaille à ce moment-là
sur des pneus de compétition,
Moto GP, 24 heures du Mans.
Le genre de métier
qui sent fort la testostérone.
De mon côté, en 2018, je suis chef
de projet en ressources humaines.
Je consacre énormément de temps
et d’énergie à mon travail
sans me poser plus de questions que cela.
Sur mon temps personnel,
je profite de mon revenu de jeune active
pour faire les voyages
dont j’avais toujours rêvé.
Mais quelque chose
va venir bouleverser nos vies.
Comme probablement
un grand nombre de personnes parmi vous,
nous découvrons avec stupeur
que nous étions complètement passés à côté
d’un enjeu majeur de notre siècle,
le changement climatique.
Un soir, je découvre Jean-Marc Jancovici.
Le lendemain, que le GIEC existe.
Et le jour d’après,
que globalement
nous sommes dans la panade.
En quelques semaines, je me prends
un raz de marée sur le coin de la figure.
Fini pour moi l’extase
devant des voitures qui tournent
en rond le plus vite possible.
Place à l'angoisse.
A peu près à cette époque.
Pendant plusieurs jours,
j’enchaîne les mini-documentaires
sur le réchauffement climatique,
l’extinction des espèces,
la déforestation.
Jusqu’à tard dans la nuit, je scrolle
sur les réseaux sociaux
de vidéos alarmistes en vidéos alarmistes.
À un moment, quelque chose
se casse en moi.
Il y a cette énorme dissonance cognitive,
que je refoulée depuis des années,
qui éclate.
Je me rends alors compte que ma vie
est complètement désalignée
avec les enjeux environnementaux.
Fini pour moi les voyages en avion
à l'autre bout du monde.
Je décide d’arrêter l’avion
purement et simplement
et du jour au lendemain,
je deviens végétarienne.
Le problème c’est que si nous voyons
à peu près comment agir
dans notre vie quotidienne
c’est beaucoup plus difficile
dans notre vie professionnelle.
Je peux trier les déchets, certes,
mais franchement, à quoi bon,
si le lendemain, à mon arrivée au travail,
je dois demander à un opérateur
de monter un pneu large comme ça,
c’est un pneu de compétition
de le mettre sur un banc d’essai,
lui faire subir des tests en tout genre
et finir par le cramer en 30 minutes.
C’est comme si je devais m’efforcer
d’oublier ce que j’avais compris
de l’urgence de la situation
pour trouver le courage
d’aller travailler.
Avec Alexis, nous avons beau faire
notre travail consciencieusement,
nous avons maintenant
l’impression d’être à côté de la plaque.
Nous ne nous consacrons
pas aux vrais enjeux.
C'est comme si on gaspillait
notre énergie, notre temps.
Ce ressenti, il est difficile à vivre
et nous sommes de plus en plus nombreux
et nombreuses à en faire l’expérience.
Et ça a un nom : l’éco-anxiété.
Au plus fort de mon anxiété,
je comprends que j’ai en réalité
deux choix devant moi :
sombrer dans la déprime
ou tenter quelque chose.
Le premier déclic intervient
lorsque je réalise
qu’il existe chez Michelin des personnes
qui partagent
les mêmes préoccupations que moi.
Comme moi, ils ont compris
l’urgence de la situation
et comme moi, ils se sentent perdus
sur la manière d’agir.
Alors, plutôt que chacun reste
dans son coin à ronger son frein,
je décide d’organiser des repas
à cinq ou six personnes
pour échanger tout simplement
le temps d'un déjeuner.
Nous partageons nos craintes, nos envies,
nos espoirs, nos idées aussi
et j’ai vraiment l’impression
qu’il se passe quelque chose.
Alors je décide de remettre ça
et à chaque fois,
des nouvelles personnes nous rejoignent.
De mon côté, chez Suez, nous échangeons
beaucoup avec mes collègues
qui, eux aussi, se sont pris
la claque environnementale
et nous parlent entre nous des engagements
qu’on aimerait
que notre entreprise prenne.
À un moment, ces discussions
ne nous suffisent plus
et nous décidons d’aller plus loin.
Nous publions un manifeste pour exprimer
notre envie de nous engager.
Ce manifeste, nous le diffusons
à notre réseau interne.
Quelques dizaines d’adresses mail
de personnes que nous connaissons,
qui à leur tour, le partagent.
Un manifeste qu’on avait rédigé
à deux ou trois
parle tout à coup
à une multitude de personnes.
Et on reçoit en retour une déferlante
d’authenticité et de mercis
de la part de personnes
qui se reconnaissent
dans cette envie d’agir.
Et chacun, dans notre entreprise,
nous observons quelque chose
d’assez magique.
Des salariés de tous horizons se mettent
progressivement à rejoindre le mouvement.
Il y a des jeunes et des moins jeunes,
des personnes de la finance,
de la supply chain, de la recherche
en usine et bien d’autres encore.
Des personnes que nous ne connaissions
ni d’Ève ni d’Adam,
mais qui partagent toutes cette envie
de contribuer positivement
à l’avenir de cette planète.
Nous sommes rapidement 30,
puis 50,
puis 100,
et nous ne le savons pas encore,
mais à ce moment-là vient de naître
dans nos organisations respectives
un collectif.
Un collectif, c’est un groupe de personnes
qui sont attachées à leur entreprise
et qui agissent de l’intérieur
pour l’aider à s’aligner
sur le gigantesque défit écologique
qui se présente à nous.
Un collectif, c’est un mouvement
organique transverse qui s’auto-gère,
où chacun lance
des projets qui aident l’entreprise
à avancer sur les sujets écologiques,
à petite mais aussi à grande échelle.
Dans un collectif, les salariés prennent
sur leur temps personnel, sur leur soirée,
sur leur pause déjeuner, pour se consacrer
à des projets qui leur tiennent à cœur
pour l’environnement
et pour leur entreprise.
Alors l’aventure aurait pu continuer
comme ça,
Alexis et ses collègues
chez Michelin et nous chez Suez.
Mais il se passait en réalité quelque
chose de beaucoup plus grand que cela.
En avril 2021, l’Association des étudiants
pour un réveil écologique
nous met en relation avec d’autres
collectifs de salariés engagés.
C’est là que je rencontre
Pauline, de Suez,
mais aussi Quentin du BCG,
Eva d’EDF ou Hassen d’Alstom,
Tiphaine d’Ubisoft
et des dizaines d’autres.
Et dire que je pense avoir eu
une idée originale en créant ce collectif.
En réalité, je réalise qu’il existe
une multitude de salariés
d’autres entreprises
qui ont eu la même démarche
avec à chaque fois
les mêmes valeurs et principes.
Les modalités d’actions
et des actions, il y en a.
Certains ont mis en place des plans
de mobilité vélo, d’autres ont déployé
des plans de formation
sur les enjeux climatiques
à l’échelle de toute l’entreprise.
D’autres encore ont mené des études
sur le plan d’épargne entreprise
pour savoir si l’argent des salariés
finançait des activités vertueuses.
Certains enfin ont monté
des groupes de réflexion
sur l’alignement entre la stratégie
de l’entreprise et les limites planétaires
et proposé de nouveaux modèles d’affaires.
Partout, un foisonnement d'idées,
d'énergies, d'actions.
Partout, des salariés qui prennent à bras
le corps des petits et grands sujets
liés à l’environnement.
Alors, pour que les succès des uns
puissent inspirer les autres,
nous choisissons de créer l’association
Les Collectifs pour mettre en réseau
les différents collectifs d’entreprises
et pour que ce mode d’engagement
grandisse et fasse la différence.
Car au sein du collectif de chacun,
le champ d’action se limite
à une entreprise.
Avec l’association Les collectifs,
ce champ d’action devient le monde
de l’entreprise tout entier
et va même au-delà.
En définitive, si vous choisissez
de rejoindre une entreprise
ou de rester dans la vôtre,
vous n’êtes, vous ne serez pas seul.
Lancez-vous.
Initiez une première action.
Créez un groupe de travail
dans votre entreprise,
il y en a pour vous soutenir
et vous inspirer.
Des milliers de salariés engagés
dans des collectifs.
L'ampleur de la tâche qui nous attend
collectivement est immense.
Et si demain tous les salariés qui portent
des convictions partent des entreprises,
il ne restera plus que les partisans
du business as usual
et nous aurons tous perdu la bataille
de l’environnement.
S’engager, c’est aussi commencer
une aventure qui forge notre vie.
Au-delà de reprendre un rôle actif
dans notre vie professionnelle
et dans la préservation
de l’environnement,
nous réinventons notre rapport au travail
et nous avançons dans notre quête de sens.
Car ce que l’on ne soupçonnait pas
avant de démarrer cette aventure,
c’est la puissance des liens humains
que nous avons créés.
En un clin d’œil, des salariés anonymes
deviennent des proches
au côté desquels nous nous sentons
vivants et agissants.
Les manières
d’avoir de l’impact sont nombreuses.
Selon vos envies, votre personnalité,
vous seul pouvez trouver l’engagement
qui vous correspond.
Ce qu’on vous garantit,
c’est que si vous choisissez
de rejoindre une entreprise
et que vous voulez la transformer
de l’intérieur,
nous serons là pour vous soutenir.
Soyez les bienvenus
dans la grande famille Les Collectifs.